the default position before this would
have allowed children to get that gender
affirming help well there's now an
entire industry which is moving shocking
numbers of children into a pathway which
is almost inevitably going to lead to
permanent medicalization for the rest of
their lives and often
lifechanging irreversible and I would
say mangling surgery it's more advanced
in the US and more culturally entrenched
than in the UK and while especially
Continental Europe is starting to move
away from this for the US it's become a
political cause and I I think we're in
the midst of a major medical Scandal
that we will look back on in much the
same way that we look back on giving
people lobotomies to solve their mental
illness I just think the results are
Gastly